字幕: Kyoko Kamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さん こんにちは
佐藤政樹と申します
今日はどうぞよろしくお願いいたします
僕は大学卒業後にフリーターになりました
その時 何を思ったか
劇団四季に入りたいという夢を持ちまして
そこから５年間 猛特訓を積んで
28歳手前で合格し
そして入団８年目に
主役をやらせていただいたという
ちょっと変わった経歴を持っております
20代 30代と
どうやったら相手に伝わるのか
お客様がどうやったら感動してくれるのか
こういったことを追究して生きてきました
皆さんも日々の生活の中で
どうやったら自分の想いが相手に伝わるのか
どうやったらお客様に感動が届くのか
こういったことを考えたことが
あると思います
しかし多くの方が 伝わるとか感動の部分を
感覚として捉えていると思うんですよね
そこで今日は大人から始めて
わからないことを徹底的に頭で考えて
体に叩き込んできた僕がですね
伝わるとか感動の部分を
感覚ではなくて
しっかりと見える化して
皆さんにお伝えしてみたいと思いますので
どうぞ楽しみにしていてください
最初にですね 僕が実際に伝わったのを
感動した体験がありますので
それを皆さんにシェアしたいと思います
結婚式の友人スピーチでの場面です
新郎新婦のふたりのキューピッド役の男女が
スピーチをしたんですね
まず女性からスピーチをしました
司会者が「キューピッド役の○○さんです」
というように こうやって呼びます
そしたら女性がこうやって立ち上がるんです
歩いてくるときからかっこいいんです
こうやって
「ダイゴさん ミキさん
今日はご結婚おめでとうございます」ってね
もう本当にアナウンサーのように
話すのが上手いなぁ 話し方の先生かなぁ
あぁこの人慣れてるんだなぁというように
僕自身も思いました
そして最後に「おめでとうございます」
と言って帰っていったんですね 綺麗に
滑舌もすごい良かったです
そしておめでたい場ですので
拍手がこうやって起きます
（スピーカーの拍手）
次がすっごいおもしろかったんです！
男性！
「それではキューピッド役の○○さんです」て
司会者が言いました
そしたらゲストの方が男性の方を
こうやって見ますよね
僕も見ました
そしたらですね
男性がすっごいおもしろかったんです
立った瞬間に顔が真っ青なんですよ
で 前に行きます
その時 手と足がこうやって一緒なんです
彼はポケットからメモを出しました
メモを読み始めます
「ダイゴさん…ミ…ミキさん ご結婚……」
（手で持つ紙が震える音）
「お おめ おめでとうございます」
ゲストの方がですね
ザワザワザワザワとなって —
「おい大丈夫か！？」
みたくなったんですよ
女性から「がんばれー！」
みたいな声も聞こえてくるんですよ
ちなみに女性の方
男性って「がんばれー！」って
みんなの前で言われるとかなりヘコむので
ちょっと覚えておいてください
（笑）
はい 情けなくなっちゃうんですよね
はい —
で なんでしたっけ？
そう！この彼がね
こうやって読んでたんです
読めない もう震えちゃって
（紙が震える音）
彼がここでおもしろい行動をとりました
「チクショー」って言ったんですよ
（笑）
「チクショー チクショー！」
と言って
この紙を捨てたんです
こうやって
で 捨てて その彼は自分の言葉で
語り始めました
「ダイゴ ミキ 俺な
俺の企画したあのバーベキューが
ふたりが出会って結婚することになるなんて
俺 思いもしなかったよ」と
語り始めたんですね
その瞬間みんなシーンとなって
彼の言葉をこうやって聴き始めました
一番感動した —
みんな感動したんですけども
僕もこうやってグッときました
一番感動したのは新郎
あまりの変わりっぷりに
強面の彼だったんですけども
目を熱くしてるんですね こうやって
真っ赤にして泣きそうになってるんです
そしたらこの彼が
何を言ったか —
「おまえが 泣くなんて反則だよ」て言って
こうやって後ろ向いちゃったんですよ
ゲストの人がいるのに
後ろ向いちゃったんです
でも この背中が語ってるんですよ
言葉がないんです
言葉がないのにこの背中が語っている
その背中を見て
僕も胸がグーッと熱くなりました
彼は振り返って自分の言葉で最後に
「おめでとう」って言って
こうやって帰っていったんです
サーっと逃げるように
その瞬間 もうゲストの人たち
拍手がブワーってなりました
一体となったんですね
つまり彼は感動を —
本当に全員の感動を巻き込んでいたんです
僕自身も感動し 結婚式が終わった後に
みんなの言葉が聞こえてきました
「あいつ全部一人で持ってっちゃったな」て
言ってたんですよ
彼は話すのが上手いか下手かで言ったら
相当下手くそだと思うんです
センスがあるかないかって言ったら
センスは相当ないと思うんですね
滑舌が悪いかいいかって言ったら
悪いです
でも彼は
自分の言葉で語ることによって
会場を感動の渦に
巻き込んでいったんですね
皆さん 日常でもこういったことは
あると思います
例えばプレゼンテーションの資料
立派な資料を用意しても
なんかイマイチ惹かれない人
ホワイトボードを使ってこうやって
丁寧に汚い字で書くんだけど
ぐいぐい引き込まれてくる人
同じ営業の文章を読んでも
売れる人 売れない人がいます
「ボクは〜！」とか
「私はこの講座を受けてー！」とか
こうやって感情を超えて語ることによって
伝えようとしていても なんか引いてしまう人
感情とかこもっていないんだけど
なんかグイグイ引き込まれてくる人
こういう人いませんか？
なぜこういうことが起きるんでしょうかね
それをですね 理解するために
今日は３つの意識のスタンスっていうのを
皆さんにご紹介したいと思います
それがこちらです
まず一つ目ですね
私たちの意識のスタンス一つ目
それが「頭」です
頭に意識がいってる時というのは
こういう時です
例えば 次何喋ろうか考えてる時
このメモをこうやって読んでいるだけの時
分析的なアピールですよね
そしてもう一つです
もう一つは意識が
この「胸」にいってる時です
胸にいってる時は こういう時が多いです
緊張している時
ドキドキ緊張している時
必死に伝えようとしている時
頑張って一生懸命な時
言葉に感情を込めようとした時
こういった時って大抵
意識が胸にいってるんですよね
そしてもう一つ
意識の置き所があります
それがこちらです
「肚」ですね
肚に意識が落とし込まれると
こういったことが起きます
「なんかあの人 説得力があるよね」
「なんかあの人 据わってるよね」
「何かあっても動じないよね」
「なんか存在感あるよね」
それでいてなんか自然体
日本では 何か一歩深い
相手とのコミュニケーション
そして一歩深い自分自身の思いを
相手に届ける時に
この「肚」というキーワードを
たくさん使ってきました
例えば「肚を割って話す」
「はらわたが煮えくりかえる」
「肚を決める」「肚をくくる」
「肚に落ちる」
なぜならばこの「肚」が自分自身の命を
輝かせる起点と考えてきたからなんですね
とにかくプロの舞台の世界では
全てが肚、肚、肚でした
ダンスも肚なんです
ダンスやる人には当たり前なんです
肚っていうのは
例えばですよ お腹を決めるんです
ダンスやる人っていうのは
お腹が決まっていない人というのは
こうなります
体がぶれるんですよね
でもダンスやってる人は
絶対この肚を決めて意識するんです
そうしたらこうなるんです
体がぶれませんよね
ジャンプする時も同じなんです
お腹が決まっていないとこうなります
でもお腹を決めることによって
こうやってなっていくんですね
普通のこういった踊りとかにしても同じです
この肚を意識するんです
そうするとですね
本当にバランスが整ってくるんですよね
ダンスやる人はこの肚は
本当に基本中の基本です
肚の移動なんです
ターンも同じ
でもこれ ダンスだけではないんです
言葉のニュアンスも 全く同じなんですね
言葉の意識の置き所です
私たちは言葉を 発します
言葉を発するんですけど この言葉には
発する理由というのが必ずあるんです
言葉は発する理由があって
それが一致して初めて言葉になってるんですね
例えば「美味しい」だったら
「美味しい」って発声する理由があるから
初めて「美味しい」って言葉が
出てくるんです
この意識 言葉の意識の置き所が
頭に来ている場合
頭に落とし込まれている場合は
これは「唱えてる」って言います
「美味しいー」こういう感じですよね
この言葉の意識が胸にきている場合
多くの人が
ここでアプローチしようとするんです
特にこうやって人前に立って
何かをやろうとした時
一生懸命やらなきゃ 一生懸命伝えなきゃ
そして言葉に感情を込めなきゃ
言葉に感情を込めて
伝えようとするんですね
例えば「美味しい！」とかって
こういう風に言葉に
感情を込めて伝えようとするんです
これが本人がやった気になるからなんですね
でも言葉に感情を込めることが
お金をもらえるかもらえないかで言ったら
表現の世界ではもらえない方向に
行ってしまいがちです
自分が楽しいか
お客さんが楽しいかで言ったら
自分が楽しい方向に
行ってしまいがちなんです
見てる人が感動するか
感動しないかで言ったら
感動しない方向に行ってしまいがち
ではどうしたらいいか
みなさん もうお判りですよね
はい その言葉を発する理由というのを
肚落ちさせていくんです
それが「お客さんを喜ばせる」
ということなんですね
これを演劇の世界では
「フレージングを磨く」と言ったりもします
「フレージングを磨く」
その言葉を発する理由の背景を
徹底的に調べて
発する理由を肚落ちさせていくんですね
「美味しい」でいったら「美味しい」って
言葉に感情を込めるんではなくて
その背景 —
飲んで感動したんだったら
「美味しい」
「美味しい！」って表現するのではなくて
その発する理由を肚落ちさせて
語っていくんです
このTED[x]のテーマはですね
今回 “Fusion” というのがありました
この “Fusion” を考えてみます
これを言語化できたりもしているんです
それがこちらです
[実感して語る]
演劇の世界では「フレージングを語る」と
いうんですけども
これは「実感して語る」ということに
言語化できます
なぜその言葉を発するのか
その言葉を発する理由を演じるのではなく
感情を込めるのではなく
ただただシンプルに
やろうとせずに
その言葉を発する理由を
実感して語っていくんですね
例えば 僕がある台詞を
もらったとしましょう
「本当に不思議な気持ちなんだ
なんだか胸が締め付けられるみたいで」
という台詞をもらったとします
この時にですね 例えば
頭に意識がいってるとこうなります
（棒読み）「本当に不思議な気持ちなんだ
なんだか胸が締め付けられるみたいで」
こうなるんですね
これで 喜ぶ人はいます
例えば子どもの発表会だったら
ご両親ですね
「うちの子が大きくなった！こんな舞台に出て
台詞[がある]発表会に出てる！」
「うぅっ！」って嬉しくなるんですよね
そして多くの方が
何か人前に立って表現してってなったら
感情を込めて表現しようとするんですね
そうするとこうなります
（大げさに）「本当に不思議な気持ちなんだ！
なんだか 胸が締め付けられるみたいで！」
こうなるんですよね
これは本人がやった気になるんです
「これが伝わる」と思うんですね
ここが 表現する側と受け取る側の違いの
面白いところです
じゃあどうするか？
さっき言った通りです
その言葉を発する理由、背景を
徹底的に考えていく
「本当に不思議な気持ちなんだ なんだか
胸が締め付けられるみたいで」だったら
恋をしたことのない男性が女性を見て
雷ドーン！って打たれて
「なんだこれは？
胸がドキドキしてくる—
なんだろうこのときめきは
不思議な気持ちだ」というところを
実感して語っていくんです
そうするとこうなります
ちょっとやってみます
（感情を込めて自然に）
「本当に不思議な気持ちなんだ
なんだか胸が締め付けられるみたいで」
（大げさに）
「本当に不思議な気持ちなんだ！
なんだか胸が締め付けられるみたいで」
とは違いませんか？
こうやってね 言葉を
一個一個落とし込んでいくんです
ミュージカルの歌も同じなんです
ミュージカルの歌も
何故その言葉を発するのか
歌詞の内容を実感して語ります
歌っちゃいけないんですよね
だから例えばですね
歌で「なんだか素敵な気持ちだ〜」
という歌があったとしましょう
これを「（歌）なんだか素敵な気持ちだ〜」と
歌っちゃいけないんですよ
ミュージカルが嫌いな人って
結構いらっしゃるんですね
嫌いな人？
あ いないですねぇ
ありがとうございます
結構いるんですよ 特に男性
何故かと言うと
急に踊り出す
（笑）
急に歌いだす
大げさ 嘘くさい
これがですね 特に「急に歌い出す」
これちょっとやってみたいと思います
（台詞）「本当に不思議な気持ちなんだ！
なんだか 胸が締め付けられるみたいで！」
（歌）「なんだか素敵な気持ちだ〜」
これがね 気持ち悪いんですよ（笑）
急に歌いだすんですね
でも表現して感動してもらうには
どうしたらいいか
さっき言った「ここから上」じゃなくて
「ここから下」なんです
ちょっとやってみます
（台詞 自然に）
「本当に不思議な気持ちなんだ
なんだか胸が締め付けられるみたいで」
（歌 語るように）
「なんだか素敵な 気持ちだ〜」
てなると自然に入れるんですよ
歌の部分にね
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
だからここから上
上辺の表現で雰囲気でやるか
その言葉を一個一個
落とし込めているかによって
見てる側は全然違ってくるんですよね
この肚に落とし込んで表現する
実感して語るって 結構怖いです
自分がやった気しないんですよ
やった方が伝わると思っちゃうので
でもそうではなくて
お客さんが感動する 伝わるっていうのは
肚に落ちた部分なんですよね
さっきの結婚式の彼もそうです
こうして唱えてました 最初は
でも「チクショーチクショー！」って
泣きそうになったんですけど
そこをグッと抑えて
バン！と捨てたんですよね
そして自分の言葉で語り始めたんです 彼は
滑舌は悪かったかもしれないけども
そこにそのエネルギーがこもっていたんですね
だから聞いてる人が
彼の本気の想いというのを感じ取った訳です
これは舞台の世界だけで
考えられることではないと思います
私たちの日常でもこれは
通じることだと思うんですよね
例えば挨拶です
舞台の世界って挨拶が
ものすごく厳しいんです
挨拶できない人って生き残れません
何故かというと 挨拶って
コミュニケーションの基本だからです
言葉を投げます
「おはよう」って
そしたら受け取ります
受け取って返すんですよね
この言葉のキャッチボールの基本が
挨拶なんです
だから普段から
「おはようございます」とか
「よろしくお願いします」というのを
実感して語る
「本当の挨拶」っていいます
こういったのを日常から訓練してるんですね
さぁいざ舞台に立ったら「本当の挨拶」とか
「本当の言葉」を語れるかっていったら
そういうことできないんです
日常ができていないのに
舞台上でできますか？っていう話です
だから普段挨拶できない子って舞台上でも
やっぱりキャッチボールが成立しません
投げても受け取ってくれないんです
受け取ったとしても
違う方向に投げちゃいます
これはもうわかるんです
キャッチボールができてないってことに
なので 私たちの普段の挨拶 —
（気だるそうに）
「おはようございまーす」って唱えていないか
それとも今日学校に来て 会社に来て
１日頑張りましょうって想いが
実感して語れるか
「おはようございます」
「よろしくお願いします」というだけでも
お互いの目も輝いてくるし 雰囲気も
一気に良くなってくると思うんですよね
あと例えばお店に入った時の
「いらっしゃいませ」とかもそうだと思います
（棒読み）「いらっしゃいませー」と言うか
「いらっしゃいませー！！」と
大きな声出すか
それとも小さな声かもしれないけども
実感して「いらっしゃいませ」って
語れているお店って
すごくスタッフ同士の雰囲気もいいですよね
また来たいと思いませんか？
例えばお店に入って
（棒読み）「いらっしゃいませー
唐揚げいかがっすかー 只今揚げたてでーす」
という唐揚げを 買いたいと思いますか？
本当に唱えるんではなくて
（自然に）「今唐揚げ揚げたてなんですけど
いかがですか 美味しいですよ」っていう風に
言葉をこうやってプレゼントできたら
「あ 買ってみようかな」っていう風に
思いますよね
そうしたらやっぱり消費なんかも
上がってくると思います
「また行きたいな」ていう風に
思うと思います
ということで 今からですね
僕が皆さんにですね
言葉のキャッチボールを
やってみたいと思います
こどもミュージカルとか
結構出てたんですけども
子どもは本当にこの
上辺か下かってわかっちゃうんです
僕がですね
「こんにちは」という風に言います
そしたら「こんにちは」って
返してみてください
その時 僕は本気でいきますので
ぜひ本気で返してみてください
よろしいでしょうか？
実感して返してみてください
ではこっちからいきます
こっちいって最後にみんなでいきます
いきます
皆さん こんにちは！
（客席右側）こんにちは
こんにちは！！
（会場左側）こんにちは
こんにちわーーー！！！
（会場全体）こんにちはーー！！
あぁ嬉しいです！
ありがとうございます
（拍手）
このような「実感して語る」という
一歩深いコミュニケーションというのは
自分も元気にするし
相手も元気にすると思います
それが社会を明るく楽しく
元気にすると思います
ぜひ皆さん これを日常でですね
視点を変えて意識して使ってみてください
ありがとうございました
（拍手）